Hey Brother
just checking in
looks like some of the other boys come
by today
it's a lot of flowers
did you ever think you'd be getting a
bunch of flowers from guys in the
Platoon
I sure didn't
but there you go
that looked good for a little while
anyway
then they'll wilt
and brown
then the grave keeper will take them
away
nothing stays forever
I wish you could have stayed a little
longer though
I'd really like to see you smile again
hear you laugh
your laugh
made other people laugh
me included
a little extra joy in the world
joy that is gone now
I missed that
I miss you
but the world moves on
time stops for no man look at me
gray hair
wrinkled skin
I'm the old guy we used to laugh about
Who's Laughing Now
even my kids are all grown up
they're not kids anymore
you'd be proud
time goes by quick
you taught me that
you taught me so much
at first
I was angry
angry you angry at myself
just angry at the world
I couldn't understand why
why you
why were you taken from this world
taken from me
my anger Guru
but it was all for me
selfish
eventually the anger consumed itself
I realized that my anger was
unwarranted
and over time
it diminished
and instead I became
thankful
thankful to have known you
thankful to have spent time with you
thankful to served alongside you
thank you to call you friend and brother
thankful
for this life you have given me
you won't grow old
so I can
your dreams were lost
so my dreams could be found
your hopes were extinguished
so my hopes
could be realized
your future was cut short
so my future
could flourish
in your death
you gave me life
and I will live this life to the fullest
I promise
I will not squander a moment
not a breath
not a laugh
not a sunset
I will live to honor the gift you gave
me
the life I owe to you
I will never forget
until next time
your brother